hey Tom people welcome to the Ruben
report i'm dave rubin I've got Beth
troutman Jimmy door with me let's jump
into nooks because President Obama
yesterday said that his biggest worry
isn't Russia it's actually that a
nuclear bomb might go off in New York
City I moved from your about a year ago
so I'm feeling pretty good about this
but not only that but just a couple days
ago in the Netherlands a group of world
leaders got together to play some
nuclear war games to sort of figure out
the planning and preparation and fallout
no pun intended if a nuclear bomb was to
go off in a major metropolitan area so
each world leader had a computer tablet
with touch screen options to make one of
four responses to a series of four
scenario films played out by actors so
they literally were watching actors act
out this this situation in the war game
a terrorist attack with an atomic dirty
bomb takes place in the financial heart
of an unnamed but western metropolis
this is probably New York if it's in the
case of the United States and in a
competitive environment with a ticking
clock the world leaders had to make
rapid choices before the results were
presented to the group followed by
discussion so that I think this is
really fascinating so they're basically
we're sort of playing like a real-time
half video game half acted out real
people response thing to something
pretty horrific so I'll start with just
the the base level thing is this
inevitable is a nuke going off in one of
our cities anywhere not just the United
States is it just ultimately inevitable
that this will happen well let's hope
not i mean i hope the idea is that
diplomacy communication things like that
can prevent a nuclear weapon a nuclear
bomb from going off in one of our cities
the thing that I found really
fascinating about this was Chancellor
Merkel mm-hmm thinking that this was
such a strange thing for these leaders
to be doing and I found that as a woman
hilarious because women we sit around
watching guys play video games thing
what this has no real world application
this isn't going to help you achieve or
do anything and you've got Chancellor
Merkel in this situation with these men
playing on their tablets in this kind of
wargame scenario thinking this isn't
what we really need to be focusing our
time energy
and attention on is a war game video
game going to prevent this from going
off I would say no I don't think that
this is necessarily going to be the way
that we're going to prevent it from
happening but I i think i would like to
think that it's not inevitable and
that's a very rose-colored glasses way
of looking at things but i don't want to
live in that kind of fear yeah well you
can't live in that here i actually
that's a pretty great visual i picture
now Angela Merkel as the mother and all
the rest of the guys downstairs playing
video games get outside crazy kids uh
what is it inevitable that this kind of
thing I mean with the way dirty bombs in
that now it can be done in a suitcase
all that is it inevitable no matter how
much they prepare that one day this kind
of thing is gonna happen so uh I when I
first heard Brock say that I thought I
can't believe that hasn't happened
already and then I thought about it a
little bit more I realize that well
member they tried to have a couple of
terrorists and an SUV in Manhattan right
and they could even get the freaking SUV
bomb to blow up right so this guy's
basically got a firecracker in his car
he can't get it to work so then there
was the guy with the bomb on the plane
he couldn't get it to work and so I'm
like I think even if they do get
attorney Bob they probably won't get it
to work they won't get we have lucked
out a couple times right with ya with
the shoe guy and the underwear guy
things that don't really work out what
do you make of Obama saying this though
the way shocking and bizarre because he
is so measured and controlled so it's
one thing if he truly isn't that
concerned about Russia I think that's
okay and we have to let diplomacy work
but the idea that he just suddenly out
of nowhere said well you know our most
important city it might feed destroyed
by you seem sort of out of character for
him it seemed like a strange political
move I mean in my mind it was him trying
to take the focus off of Russia off of
Putin off of what's going on at all is
the criticism that he's getting for his
foreign relations his paw you think he
was just like oh let me say the craziest
thing possible that our scare the [ __ ]
out of everybody that was one of the
things that I that was my first instinct
reaction whatever i heard him say that
because suddenly if you hear the
president say that then your fear goes
in a different direction yeah I can't I
thought about like whoa what are the
people in New York thinking when they
hear that you know you imagine if you're
a kid in school and the president on TV
says we're worried about someone blowing
up New York with a bomb what the half
are you
me should I be scared all the time
president saying and I did I thought
that was irresponsible of him to say it
like that would scare the [ __ ] out of
people living in there and I also think
it's funny whenever they call it a dirty
bomb yeah it just makes me laugh a
little because you know my parents
always castigate me for swearing in my
comedy so much my gonna be so very way
it sounds like the Baba's is coming all
the way it's going [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] rejected everybody else yet yeah
such a dirty Bob uh look obviously we're
not privy to all the stuff that's going
on with these games or what's really
going on with who has nukes and all that
kind of stuff and scientists that you
know defect from countries and all that
but do you think these games actually do
anything cuz they've been doing these
for years this isn't the first time
they've done this kind of thing uh but
it makes me think if a new quiz to go
off somewhere let's let's get out of
America for a second let's say went off
in Paris how about that uh do you think
the games would actually matter he's
going frickin French freedom fries you
still on that freedom um do you think
the games would mean anything because I
feel like there would be such chaos and
such a cascading effect of lunacy that
none of the things that they're doing
would really would really mad I couldn't
agree with you more yes don't you try to
plan for a nuclear war huh hey let's
play a flag plan for when your head
blows up okay let when what should i do
after my head blows up well first you
put a bandage around it like know it so
I think it's all you know what's a
nuclear bomb goes off that's it games
over right don't you think I do yes they
seemed I mean they have I guess they
have to look very diligent but they they
hijacked a plane and flew it into
buildings in New York and we invaded
Iraq and Afghanistan what do you think
if someone blows off a book what how
well so we're gonna strike somebody with
a nuclear bomb yeah I mean it's a one
goes off it really seems like a domino
to me yeah well that is a good point
because if one went off here we would
nuke somebody we somebody weight in a
week we would nuke somebody even even
with Obama who obviously isn't as
militant let's say although he's done
some strange things with drones which
will get you later as explosion um so is
this just really like you know every
science fiction movie I've ever seen
where humans are just going to destroy
the earth and we're gonna have to go
live on Elysium or on Mars or something
is that really where we're all going
with this I I think a lot of people
would say yes I think a lot of people
would say that human
been destroying the earth since humans
became humans this is just a quicker way
don't believe in evolution and edgy
stuff today very edgy what do you think
is this humans are we gonna just do it
to ourselves between greenhouse gases
and global climate change and everything
else and yeah well I wouldn't buy
property in Florida yeah I'm not I don't
think we're gonna make it past 2050 I
don't think we have to worry about
Social Security running out of money I
think we're not gonna be dead before I
don't really say Miami is gonna be
underwater and like you know you know
people don't real yes that's what I'm
saying I wouldn't buy property in
Florida and you know the whole thing
people forget like Syria what's
happening in what's destabilizing that
whole region is a drought that all
started because of a drought and people
came into the city's protesting and then
the police overreact and it started this
whole thing so you know they talk about
climate change having political
political impact it's happening right
now right it's absolutely worried about
something that's what we should really
yes about and focusing on because that's
a much larger problem and something
that's really happening I mean we
shouldn't be necessarily thinking about
playing a game and wondering what would
happen if a nuclear bomb went off we
actually have something that's like a
nuclear bomb that's going off
consistently that's causing huge
problems it just takes a longer period
of time you think we have some
progressive around here we started with
the nuclear war we brought it around to
climate change there you go